riecht nach kuchen ich dachte haschisch
so richtig
nennen sie ihre freunde michael prill ja
negro brünig also das pendelt sich so
bei mich herein
wir machen heute cake pops kennen sie
cake pops haben sie noch nie wir
zerbröseln jetzt diesen kuchen
das ist das was runter gefallen das ist
nicht so schlimm weil ich hab das
gebastelt und ich kann nicht so gut
basteln deswegen mache ich das ja ja
wenn sie seriös nicht basteln können
warum laden sieben leute ein die auch
nicht basteln können weil wir dann
gemeinsam nicht so gut sind
ich grüße sie ein bisschen himbeer
gillet dazufügen dass das gut klebt man
solle nicht zu viel nehmen sonst sonst
ist es zu mathe genie saison
ich persönlich fand finde dass bei mir
sieht das ein bisschen luftiger höhe ist
sozusagen weiß ja nicht ob es so sein
muss jedes darf nicht so sein weil wir
ich werde es ihnen gefallen habe ich
noch gesagt darf man nicht so viel
ja ich wusste ja nicht was ich gesagt
habe offensichtlich sei es als
politikerin zum beispiel schon mal
ungeeignet ich dachte es gut wenn man
irgendwas behauptet und dann einfach
sein
sein verhalten anpasst an dem resultat
nein wir müssen zwar vergessen können
aber nicht das was ich immer gesagt
haben das ist in unserem job nicht so
gut aber wenn man so wirklich was selber
machen will stichwort die western nicht
schlauer anstatt politiker einfach
lobbyist zu werden
lobbyisten haben irgendwie aus meiner
sicht falschen ruf was ist ihre
lieblings lobby die lobby des deutschen
bundestages hat kann man sich gemütlich
hinsetzen gibt es auch sessel und ja
schreibt in die kommentare ob das lustig
war ich finde ein bisschen diesen
partien schon eine ganze menge oder hier
die eiweiß total als karrieresprungbrett
also wir haben für sie ein 1 1 für die
gäste
wir waren schon da jens sparen war da
und danach wohl der minister ja julia
klöckner aber danach wurde sie
ministerin ich das gewusst hätte wäre
ich nicht gekommen was wollen wir noch
arbeit
zur werden klaren wodka soll ich denn
jetzt mit diesen handschuhen
möglicherweise noch drehen kann ihn auch
einflößten okay ich denke mit den
schuhen ist wirklich wort gab
ja klar wie kommen sie mit dem teig
voran
also ich will sie jetzt nicht abwerten
aber ihre bälle sind schöner
ich glaube ja das liegt daran dass sie
mir zu viel von dieser konfitüre hier in
den dicken rauch taschen aber das sieht
man ja auch die sind ja gar nicht so
fertig wie man nur weil aber das ist
doch kein fett das ist doch nur
kohlenhydrate
ja das macht auch nicht glitschig
deswegen haben sie mir ja auch gesagt
haben sie ist ich habe ziemlich richtig
schützen die hier ab nur weil das ist
mir japanischen gameshow das ist die
halbe miete programm dafür stehe ich mit
meinem namen
wer sind ihre freunde in der cee region
zählen mögen sie nicht so freunde habe
ich eine ganze menge aber ich weiß nicht
ob das klug ist wenn ich dir auf ziele
bei uns noch ein wodka nein auf keinen
fall
was denken sie wie weit kommen jogis
jungs halbfinale immer darüber müssen
wir nicht reden nach alter deutscher
tradition wenn die premieren in die hose
gehen
dann wartet das ganz große
erfolgserlebnis im turnier naja also
nach alter deutscher tradition kommt der
deutsche in russland nicht sehr bald das
ist auch nicht völlig falsch
also ich hab schon nicht beleibte
politiker gesehen das ist zum beispiel
eine ungelöste frage müssen vielleicht
besonders dicke abgeordnete doppelte
diäten bekommen war ein sprachlichen
spannenden satz besonders dicke anfang
noch mal nachfragen ob das irgendwie
witzig war oder so was ja sollte man
findet ihr diesen kommentar jetzt gerade
witzig dann schreibt in die kommentare
grobe fanny fanny 2 habe ich das okay
mit bis auf group ruhiger aber großer
star ist ein guter hashtag ich werde
übrigens einen fußball machen und ein
mesut özil oder ich machen schneemann
aus fußbällen daher bin ich der einzige
der jetzt noch das bastelt was hier
eigentlich sinnvoll wird
macht wirklich schon sie sind hat der
der als geschäftsführer den laden
zusammenhält und damit ist im prinzip
ein besuch schon sinnvoll gewesen damit
manches auch so wird wie es werden soll
jetzt ist eigentlich jetzt in der großen
koalition macht es spaß oder ist es mehr
so charity also wir haben nicht ihren
job der auch jeden tag spaß macht ich
habe immer spaß samt übernehmen echt
jeden morgen auf und wollen die mähne
frage also soviel sprach ja nicht dass
sie ihre vorurteile zerstört werden und
sie in politiker treffen mit dem man
unter umständen sogar humorvoll umgehen
kann
sie sind ja irgendwie was
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer der
fraktion oder hier ist dass das ist ja
nicht wirklich politiker oder das haben
ja so verleiht tief im
angloamerikanischen allerdings ohne
peitsche muss man sagen warum man das
ist echt richtig schlimm das war
ungefähr vor 30 minuten schon absehbar
fand ich ja also es wäre dann
zusammengeschnitten auf ungefähr eine
minute deswegen müsse nicht sein das war
vor fünf minuten für mich schon klar ich
mache jetzt übrigens nicht cdu cake pops
einen csu cape
gut oder haben sie auch länger dran
gearbeitet oder an diesen gag also ich
bin fertig ich habe kein wunder kann
nicht mehr ich will auch nicht die frage
ist ja womit ja eben ihr habt noch so
kleine trikots hier stimmt danke schön
man manches war nix vor gericht gar
nicht ja wir haben sonst noch kleine
tricks dabei
[Gelächter]
mir wurde gesagt
sagen sie jetzt nicht mehr kriegen noch
trick wer nach trikot
so kann nicht mehr ja das ist die
heutige generation nichts gewohnt halbe
stunde erschöpft wenn man wenigstens in
der zeit was geschafft hätte so wie ich
im fussball und ibrahimovic im deutschen
nationaltrikot
gut dass sie das probieren ich möchte
wirklich widerlich vielen dank
da habe ich mich ja besser als grube gut
das war grob tief whip und der einzige
der jeweils hingekriegt hat das hat er
es gesagt aber es stimmt
[Musik]